Caption: hi so a bit of a disclaimer upfront I'm
Caption: gonna be talking more about the notify
Caption: the data breach scheme than how to win
Caption: friends so if that's what you came for I
Caption: apologize there there was an asterisk
Caption: there so my bases are covered
Caption: really quick thank you to the sponsors
Caption: without which we wouldn't be here so
Caption: I'll start off with a bit of a feel
Caption: about means so obviously I am Cairo just
Caption: like the city in case you were wondering
Caption: I'm an information security consultant
Caption: asterisk
Caption: I'm also the per capita lead for the
Caption: Australian women insecurity network so
Caption: any of the girls out there if you're
Caption: interested in cyber security are working
Caption: in cyber security definitely hit me up
Caption: we'd love to have you coming along to
Caption: our meetups and just a bit of a
Caption: disclaimer I'm totally not a lawyer so
Caption: if you're gonna take this as legal
Caption: advice I take no responsibility for any
Caption: things that make our horribly horribly
Caption: wrong didn't I might go off cool alright
Caption: I also spend way too much time on
Caption: Twitter so follow me I want more
Caption: followers that would be great so the
Caption: main reason we are here today is to talk
Caption: about the privacy Amendment notifiable
Caption: data breaches Act of 2017 so this became
Caption: a little last February about 18 months
Caption: ago and the scheme itself officially
Caption: kicked in on February 22nd of this year
Caption: so this act basically established breach
Caption: notification obligations for entities
Caption: that are subject to the Privacy Act so a
Caption: bit of a background on the Privacy Act
Caption: its Australian federal legislation
Caption: passed in 1988 same age as me it's
Caption: Australia's main privacy and data
Caption: protection law and it's what we describe
Caption: as principles based legislation so it's
Caption: not a prescriptive list of technical
Caption: do's and don'ts that companies have to
Caption: adhere to if they
Caption: we kind of set up the high-level
Caption: aspirations that we have in terms of
Caption: privacy and data protection it's been
Caption: updated three years or three times in
Caption: the past thirty years which i think is
Caption: pretty interesting given how much
Caption: technology and privacy has changed in
Caption: that 30 years so that's something to
Caption: keep in mind the main section of the
Caption: Privacy Act is the Australian privacy
Caption: principles so this sets out the
Caption: obligations of organisations when it
Caption: comes to protecting personal information
Caption: it also sets out a lot of rights that
Caption: individuals have so this is the right to
Caption: request data is deleted the right to
Caption: have inaccurate data updated those kinds
Caption: of things one of the main things that
Caption: the Privacy Act defines is what actually
Caption: constitutes personal information
Caption: unhelpfully it defines it fairly vaguely
Caption: as information that makes it known an
Caption: individual person exists so we all know
Caption: exactly what that means same thing this
Caption: definition actually gets it changes
Caption: regularly based on how the courts
Caption: actually interpret it so I don't know
Caption: how many of you followed the case of
Caption: then Grubb a couple of years ago he's a
Caption: tech journalist and you put in a request
Caption: to Telstra to get copies of all of his
Caption: metadata when he initially made this
Caption: request the courts ruled that he could
Caption: have access to all of his IP logs
Caption: because they were logs
Caption: pertaining to his usage of a service and
Caption: therefore it was personal information
Caption: upon appeal from Telstra that
Caption: interpretation was overruled and they
Caption: decided that the IP logs actually
Caption: pertained to information about a service
Caption: rather than a person and therefore it
Caption: wasn't considered personal information
Caption: so there is that back and forth in terms
Caption: of what actually falls under this
Caption: definition so it can be a little bit
Caption: vague so that's something to keep in
Caption: mind so we'll go over a bit about the
Caption: OIC so this is the office of the
Caption: Australian Information Commission and
Caption: they're the main enforcement body for
Caption: the Privacy Act they're empowered to
Caption: investigate violations of privacy
Caption: there's two ways they can do that they
Caption: accept complaints from individuals when
Caption: they feel that an organisation has
Caption: violated their privacy or they can
Caption: initiate an investigation of their own
Caption: accord so if something hits the news or
Caption: they receive industry news about
Caption: something they can decide if they're
Caption: empowered to investigate one of the main
Caption: issues that the way I see is they are
Caption: chronically underfunded the government
Caption: doesn't really give them a lot of money
Caption: if you go on their website at the moment
Caption: and submit a general request I think
Caption: there's about a four week wait time to
Caption: actually get a response and that's just
Caption: a general email request it's not even a
Caption: complaint so that's mildly concerning
Caption: there is actually a face to be an
Caption: information Commissioner and a Privacy
Caption: Commissioner and there's supposed to be
Caption: two separate roles
Caption: they've been fulfilled by the same
Caption: person for the last couple of years
Caption: because there's not enough funding to
Caption: have to really makes us protected
Caption: so the OSD has the power to take legal
Caption: action against organisations that are
Caption: found to be in violation of the Privacy
Caption: Act they can issue fines of up to three
Caption: million dollars in the case of
Caption: I can talk really loudly oh cool well
Caption: that's cool
Caption: so in the cases of the notify but data
Caption: breach scheme I think the maximum time
Caption: they can issue is about 2.4 million they
Caption: can also do a really really fun thing
Caption: known as enforceable undertakings and I
Caption: can guarantee you that any organization
Caption: that's investigated by the OIC their
Caption: number one goal is to not get one of
Caption: them it's essentially a legally
Caption: enforceable agreement that that
Caption: organization will do everything that the
Caption: OIC tells them to do to remediate any
Caption: issues I believe Optus at one point
Caption: entered into an enforceable undertaking
Caption: and it was about five years until they
Caption: were actually done with everything they
Caption: were told to do so your opinion on that
Caption: will probably differ based on if you
Caption: work for that organization or not by
Caption: generally speaking it's a lot of work so
Caption: on to the actual notifiable data breach
Caption: scheme so unsurprisingly it basically
Caption: does what it says on the box it sets out
Caption: the notification requirements for
Caption: entities that have experienced the
Caption: breach surprise of this coming into law
Caption: notification was entirely voluntary and
Caption: unsurprisingly not a lot of
Caption: organizations decided to tell people
Caption: when they had been breached obviously
Caption: there's a financial impact reputational
Caption: impact and they don't really want to do
Caption: that
Caption: so as part of this breach their
Caption: organization has to do an assessment of
Caption: what the impact of that breach would be
Caption: to determine if it's actually eligible
Caption: for notification and once that's been
Caption: determined notification has to be
Caption: provided to both the oai scene I'm the
Caption: individuals that are affected by the
Caption: breach so there's two outcomes of this
Caption: the individuals are actually notified
Caption: that their dad has been breached and the
Caption: OAS he actually gets to gather a whole
Caption: bunch of statistics on data breaches
Caption: which is actually pretty cool the first
Caption: full quarter results have actually just
Caption: been released which you can read on the
Caption: IOC website it's really cool reading
Caption: that was not sarcastic it sounded it but
Caption: it wasn't
Caption: so the first question is what entities
Caption: are actually subject to this game so the
Caption: scheme applies to all organizations
Caption: currently subject to the Privacy Act and
Caption: this includes businesses government
Caption: agencies and not-for-profit groups that
Caption: collect personal information that's the
Caption: broad application there's a whole bunch
Caption: of exceptions to this so currently the
Caption: Privacy Act doesn't apply to businesses
Caption: with an annual turnover of less than
Caption: three million dollars a year so small to
Caption: medium enterprise don't need to comply
Caption: with it there is an exception to the
Caption: exception just to make it really easy to
Caption: follow if your organization handles tax
Caption: file numbers or health and medical
Caption: information then you do need to comply
Caption: with the notifiable data breach scheme
Caption: and I can guarantee this and are
Caption: probably going to get caught out at some
Caption: point one of the ones that concerns me
Caption: the most is it doesn't apply to state or
Caption: territory agencies or organizations so
Caption: the Privacy Act is federal legislation
Caption: and it doesn't apply to actual state
Caption: agencies because states are empowered to
Caption: make their own privacy legislation in
Caption: w-a we don't have any at this point and
Caption: if you think about the services that the
Caption: w8 government actually provides it's a
Caption: little bit concerning so that would
Caption: cover public hospitals most primary and
Caption: secondary schools that kind of stuff a
Caption: little bit concerning and there's also
Caption: an exception for registered political
Caption: parties so they can do whatever they
Caption: want with your data and employee records
Caption: also aren't covered under the Privacy
Caption: Act those are covered by workplace
Caption: relations legislation the exception to
Caption: that exception I'm sensing a theme here
Caption: is that if you as an organization do
Caption: outsource the management of your
Caption: employee records then it is subject to
Caption: the notifiable data breaches scheme
Caption: which is why there was the big major
Caption: breach recently had all of those
Caption: organizations been handling their own
Caption: data they wouldn't have actually had
Caption: tell anyone so take from that what you
Caption: will so in this case you only need to
Caption: know five for Dad for the data breaches
Caption: that are deemed to be eligible so first
Caption: up we need to define what a breach
Caption: actually is so the OU AIC defines a data
Caption: breach as unauthorized access or
Caption: disclosure of data as well as the loss
Caption: of data where it could then lead to
Caption: unauthorized access so if you
Caption: accidentally wipe all of your data
Caption: that's fine if you leave all of your
Caption: data on a hard drive on a bus and
Caption: someone may get hold of it not quite so
Caption: fine so we're all they're only talking
Caption: about breaches that involve personal
Caption: information corporate data is not
Caption: covered so if you work for a company and
Caption: your corporate data gets hacked we don't
Caption: care really let's be honest but it's
Caption: your own problem and the final
Caption: requirement is that the breach has to be
Caption: likely to result in serious harm to the
Caption: individual whose data has been breached
Caption: so this is a pretty big question what
Caption: actually constitutes serious harm
Caption: there's no again no legal definition of
Caption: what exactly that means the OU AIC has
Caption: issued this guidance which specifically
Caption: calls out physical psychological
Caption: emotional economic and financial harm as
Caption: well as harm to your reputation so
Caption: there's a whole list of things that this
Caption: could involve but the thing that kind of
Caption: gets me is the requirement for a
Caption: reasonable person in the entity's
Caption: position would identify this as a
Caption: possible outcome of the data breach so
Caption: essentially what this situation leads to
Caption: is you have an organization doing an
Caption: impact assessment of a breach on behalf
Caption: of the people who are actually affected
Caption: and that organization generally speaking
Caption: is going to have a vested interest in
Caption: determining that hey we don't actually
Caption: need to do notification so there's that
Caption: conflict of interest there which makes
Caption: me mildly uncomfortable the other thing
Caption: that is kind
Caption: issue is that as individuals we all use
Caption: a little bit of security speaker and I
Caption: apologize we all have slightly different
Caption: threat models in our lives so what's
Caption: gonna cause serious harm to mean is not
Caption: necessarily the same for other people
Caption: everyone has different things that are
Caption: going to harm them and when it comes to
Caption: an organization determining the
Caption: likelihood of serious harm its leaving
Caption: out a lot of outliers which are
Caption: generally the people who are most
Caption: vulnerable to experience harm so in
Caption: those cases we're talking about people
Caption: who've been victims of domestic violence
Caption: people with sensitive medical histories
Caption: that stuff like they might be
Caption: hiv-positive they might be sex workers
Caption: they might have they might be homosexual
Caption: and that information getting out has
Caption: much higher likelihood of causing harm
Caption: to those individuals than to people like
Caption: me who aren't really controversial and
Caption: have really only like allergic to bees
Caption: so those are the outliers that are going
Caption: to be missed in this impact assessment
Caption: and those are the people who are most
Caption: likely to be harmed so I've kind of
Caption: personally object to anything privacy
Caption: related that doesn't take into account
Caption: the most vulnerable people and that's
Caption: something we're seeing a lot with the my
Caption: health record debate that's going on at
Caption: the moment as well which I'm not even
Caption: gonna touch have enough time so in terms
Caption: of deciding that breaches are ineligible
Caption: for notification anything where you're
Caption: like there's no gonna be serious harm
Caption: but either the serious harm is unlikely
Caption: or the likely level of harm is not
Caption: serious and thirdly if you undertake
Caption: incident response activities in the case
Caption: of a breach and you've managed to reduce
Caption: the likelihood of the serious harm by
Caption: doing that then the breach is no longer
Caption: notifiable so for example let's say
Caption: you're trying to send someone's medical
Caption: records off to another GP and you're
Caption: gonna do it by email because that's what
Caption: we all do and you send that to the wrong
Caption: person if you successfully manage to
Caption: recall that email and it hasn't been
Caption: accessed no one's actually read it in
Caption: that case you've managed to prevent the
Caption: series
Caption: come and therefore it's no longer
Caption: notifiable one of the other exceptions
Caption: is if notification with interfere with
Caption: law enforcement activity so let's say
Caption: you work for an Internet service
Caption: provider you're intercepting phone calls
Caption: on behalf of law enforcement cuz you've
Caption: got a warrant hopefully if that data was
Caption: breached in that case if you actually
Caption: notified that individual you would be
Caption: compromising that investigation
Caption: so you still have to notify the oai
Caption: thing but you don't have to actually
Caption: tell the person and that determination
Caption: has to be made by the CEO of the
Caption: organization there's also a blanket
Caption: exception for secrecy provisions and
Caption: this is basically all the easier secret
Caption: squirrel stuff and finally you can apply
Caption: to that way I see to get an exception I
Caption: don't think this is ever really gonna be
Caption: used but I'd be interested to see who
Caption: tries it what the outcome is so whether
Caption: or not that would be publicized as a
Caption: whole other thing so in terms of the
Caption: notification that has to be sent out
Caption: there are some very specific
Caption: requirements so notifications to
Caption: individuals have to include obviously
Caption: the name of the organisation and how
Caption: they can contact you has to have a
Caption: description of the breach can be fairly
Caption: brief you have to include the kinds of
Caption: information that were breached so is it
Caption: just contact information is it credit
Caption: card information is it medical stuff you
Caption: have to actually disclose that and then
Caption: you also have to include recommendations
Caption: of next steps that those individuals can
Caption: take to protect themselves from serious
Caption: harm so for most situations this is
Caption: going to be something like changing
Caption: passwords may be entering into credit
Caption: monitoring cancelling credit cards or
Caption: that kind of stuff so you do need to
Caption: provide that advice I'm interested to
Caption: see what kind of liability this
Caption: introduces for people if they follow
Caption: that advice but that's something we'll
Caption: see come out as this game gets more
Caption: mature if it's not actually possible to
Caption: notify individuals directly so if you
Caption: don't have
Caption: to date contact information or something
Caption: like that you can publish your statement
Caption: covering the breach with all of the
Caption: information that would have been in a
Caption: direct notification and you also have to
Caption: take reasonable proactive steps to
Caption: actually publicize that so you can't
Caption: just hide a link in the corner of your
Caption: website and hope that no one sees it how
Caption: far the o AIC will take that well I
Caption: guess we'll see in terms of notifying
Caption: the o AIC themselves they have
Caption: unsurprisingly made this very quite
Caption: quite easy for organizations to do there
Caption: is a handy-dandy website which I put up
Caption: there but you can just google it as well
Caption: which basically contains all the
Caption: information that organizations need to
Caption: give them as part of a notification so I
Caption: guess the big question is what do you
Caption: actually do if you work for an
Caption: organization and you need to comply with
Caption: this and I'm hoping people have already
Caption: done them I'll put my security
Caption: consultant had on a number one you need
Caption: to know your stuff you need to know what
Caption: information you actually are storing
Caption: where you're storing it what you
Caption: actually do to protect it and if you
Caption: would actually know if there was a
Caption: breach if you've got no detective
Caption: controls in place you're gonna have no
Caption: idea and not knowing that you had a
Caption: breach isn't really a way to get out of
Caption: having to notify people another thing
Caption: I'd mention is definitely be considering
Caption: what information you're collecting and
Caption: why if you don't need to collect
Caption: information you probably shouldn't
Caption: because then you don't have to protect
Caption: it you should also have incident
Caption: response plans in place so once you
Caption: detect the breach hopefully you should
Caption: know how to respond you should have an
Caption: assessment process in place so that you
Caption: can actually assess that impact and show
Caption: you're working should the o AIC come
Caption: knocking and actually ask what you've
Caption: done and finally have a communication
Caption: plan in place and so you know what
Caption: you're gonna say and how you're gonna
Caption: say it if you do need to do that so
Caption: that's pretty much all I had I realized
Caption: I got through the entire thing without a
Caption: main so I've chucked it at the end
Caption: all right it was close so yeah if anyone
Caption: does have any questions I wants to chat
Caption: I'll be around all day so just hit me up
Caption: [Applause]